qué selecciones han cumplido con su
papel de favoritas y cuáles quedaron en
deuda
Pues bueno creo que Brasil y Colombia
han sido las elecciones que han afirmado
que han afirmado mejor su favoritismo en
esta copa América femenina las dos
elecciones terminaron líderes cada una
de su grupo y además
obtuvieron puntaje perfecto durante esta
fase de grupos de otro lado hablemos un
poco de los equipos de los que
esperábamos un poco más que También
tenían rótulo de favoritos pero que por
ahí no funcionó mucho también por el
estado físico y anímico de sus jugadoras
actuales hablamos de chile hablamos
también de una selección como Venezuela
Qué pasó con chile eh la arquera su
arquera la favorita quizás la mejor que
era del mundo Cristian eller no llegó en
la mejor forma física a esta copa
América ahora chile deina Castellanos no
fue Clara en los ataques no la vimos
siendo esa figura que esperaba incluso
siendo esa líder dentro de la cancha que
se esperaba para esta copa América
femenina estas elecciones se quedan por
fuera de ese tan anhelado ocupa los
Juegos Olímpicos Y de esa fase final de
esta copa América femenina